hello everybody welcome to another
hangout super excited to be here with
Travis Huff now Travis runs a podcast
called the be real podcast and he asked
me to be a guest on his show and I said
I love it let's do it but why don't we
also do it is a hangout on my channel so
people could meet him and learn about
him so Travis before getting into the
podcast why don't you give us a quick
intro on what the big wheel podcast is
all about I've already linked it up in
the description if you guys to check out
anza taking away times let's hear about
it guys how's it going today thank you
so much my name is Travis tough I have
the v-world show and it is absolute
pleasure today to be with you and Evan
Carmichael my man I'm gonna be rude with
you guys today how I found this guy on
youtube i'm looking one day for warm
blooded videos and I've seen my man top
10 the top 10 comes in I watched the
video and I literally haven't stopped
watching this video sense so shout-out
to you my man what I do with the V bro
show is we talked about life dreams
social media how you can do it for your
business and really make things happen
in your life and get great insights from
people that are doing big things look at
my man Evan where you're going to get
into my man mine is mine today and you
are going to get real with me my man so
I'm ready let's do it all right well hit
me up all right let's do this well
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the B
will show with Travis to Tolland huh I
fired up today to bring you our featured
guest today Evan Carmichael Evan are you
ready to be real I'm ready let's do it
man yes evan is an influencer a speaker
and he believes in entrepreneurs as well
as evan has his own communication group
and he's doing a ton of things on
YouTube anyone on YouTube you have to
have seen one of this top 10 rules
videos which are unbelievable and just
entrepreneurs great insights into the
mindsets of business owner so every
we've given our listeners just a little
as I but tell us what is going on today
my man I'm good I'm here to inspire and
believe in entrepreneurs man how could
it be a guest I love it I love it so
tell us a little bit more about your
passion when you've started a YouTube
channel tell us what was your real
passion behind idiot going
uh when I started the YouTube channel it
was just answering questions people
running in asking me questions about
their business and i would spend 30 45
minutes writing responses individually
and I thought this is an insane use of
time I can make a video I could help
that person that can help lots of other
people have the same problem that was
way back that's like six seven years ago
then I started that the series that
you're talking about like the top ten
two thing with Jonathan just came up
here I'll oh I love that came out of his
selfish desires for me I realized that
if I wanted to create great things I
needed a great environment I needed I
needed I needed ideas that I could
absorb into my brain and make me push me
to think bigger to do more and you know
my environment was just okay you know it
was easy to be comfortable where I was
and what I had done and had a lot of
people around me saying hey you've
already done so much congratulations and
that's great but there's nobody like
pushing me to do more and so I wanted
something where I wake up and I get a
little bit of steve jobs in my head or I
get a little bit of warm buffing in my
head or I get a little bit of you know
whoever it is and so it's entrepreneurs
it's successful athletes musicians
people who had success whatever field
there right there in you can learn from
them not just the ideas of what to do
but think the the way they think you
know I want a little bit of a warm
Buffett magic dust rubbing off on the me
ya want it a little bit more so that was
those words that was a selfish project
for me and then I just shared with
people and and people like it it took
off so i think it's unbelieving you can
spend a lot of time researching people
reading books and tons of stuff but what
you do with your videos is amazing did
you take real live video and stuff
they've said and make it so that people
can you know find out who this person is
what makes them tick what are the top
things at their core and really if you
watch all the other videos it's just the
same stuff repeated in longer formats
you know i mean so it's just a concise
way of really understanding who someone
is so shout out to my man for doing that
i love it now tell us now what keeps you
going now that you've had such heap
success already 270,000 Twitter
followers a huge
channel what keeps you going today uh
you know my big goal is to help a
billing entrepreneurs yes for me it's
not so much the like I need to hit this
goal that is motivating it's more I want
to do something everything that I do has
to have the ability to reach millions of
people I enjoy the process I enjoyed
helping entrepreneurs I enjoy doing it
on a bigger skate a stage and and that's
what like what motivates me of the
YouTube comments are the emails I get
like talking to you man like yeah
absolutely no you I feel like I know you
in person if I'm and that's a cool part
about a few is you really get to know
evidence through his videos and and your
team shot to your team to / of the
amazing production quality and editing
stuff to which is so important critical
as obviously we're all credit video you
do a really great job of making the
videos concise so that you're getting
quality content packed in there you know
and then also some live stuff like this
to which gives you a little bit more
person and what your passions are and
kind of a little more unedited but the
fact that you're doing the video my man
it makes you feel like to really know
you you know and that's the best part i
love it and so for you I'm sure you got
lots of people you bump into it and
there you haven't you know it like I
different texts me said oh and the post
this and I can't wait to be watching the
show they say shava shava and she
watching out there the point is that
it's such an unbelievable thing to
believe in your dreams and to know that
it is limitless I know you're going to
reach those billion entrepreneurs and
business owners because it is truly
living this the world is full of
abundant security on the way shorter
17,000 Twitter followers you're just a
couple steps away my man and you're
already blowing it up beyond probably
your kids right yeah you know you too is
my main focus at the moment we're adding
on a thousand subscribers a day to the
channel so yeah it's growing I like I
mean I like the numbers is good you can
get a dick but it's more the I like
knowing the impact like my goal is
impact I think if you have the if you
have the ability to help a lot of people
you should do it a lot of people have
that dream you know they have talents
they have skills they could impact a lot
of people but they don't take action on
it and I don't want to be the guy who's
like 80 years old looking back and
saying
wish I did more so I want to do for now
I want to do more now okay I love it
you're good if I went yeah got those
videos take you know 10 to 30 hours per
video to put together offices it's
really quality content that Adam yummy
Evan puts in here in the Indian really
gets it done the end of the day the most
important thing think of is all creepy
videos but to actually get them done as
hard so you can power to team where I
ever yeah we've got on the YouTube side
there's six people who work with me on
the channel the biggest chunk is the the
research like you know you take an Elon
Musk top 10 video that might be 15 not
long you know you gotta sift through 10
20 hours of his interviews and footage
of which you know there's some
interesting stuff but a lot of bitters
questions that are interesting or he
doesn't have a succinct answer and we're
just pulling out the best nuggets that
can you know hopefully change your life
in 15 minutes again that's for me like I
want a hanger-on Elon Musk more but I
don't want to sift through all that
stuff myself so we built the team I
would do this even if it wasn't being
published because I want it selfish it
for me and I'm glad that other people
like it and enjoy it too so yeah that's
it's like a double purpose for you right
it's like a great way to keep you keep
it out heart and he said I watched
multiple one he loved ones great you
know the war one I always loved cuz my
father would people leave her more
buffeted what do you have to say is
unbelievable for entrepreneurs out there
I mean it and there's a lot being done
in this case so I'm just so excited
about where your features go on my man
i'm excited that you you can give me the
chance to introduce myself to your
guests here too we're going to take you
and start with a be real store in my man
Evan take us to a time or maybe tell me
a story about when maybe you fail that
social along this journey oh man go just
go back to my youtube the stuff is
terrible uh I mean my first videos you
know it's hard to see me I have light
behind me I'm all dark the audio sucks
i'm nervous you know
camera shaking you know it's just I left
those videos up because I wanted to be
able to show the story too and anybody
can go back and find my first videos and
how it's it's night and day compared to
where it is now but this is 3,000 videos
later so it's not yeah I'm important
let's not get it twisted by man evan is
putting in the work I mean how many
videos to release on and giving a week
to Florida ah a given week we're looking
at 18 to 20 videos that is awesome and
so what happens with that too i believe
is once you've built up this huge
conglomerate of of young fans loyal
subscribers like myself and other heard
of other people are a you're on the show
that's awesome the point is that now you
put you more video content than ever and
then bounce it's going to get your brand
even bigger right the whole mission and
cause is going to be more because you
have more content than ever it's like
the Khan Academy I mean you can go to my
man Evans youtube channel and literally
learn from the best entrepreneurs in the
world it's like going to the most elite
club or college ever so I think you got
something there with just believe in
itself but maybe being its own college
in a way you know and have the
institution my man but it's all free
you're putting it out there for free so
I feel like it makes me a better
entrepreneur to be honest with you so
thank you so much that it for what
you're doing for us out there even
though you did make them separate so
suit yourself you could power that's my
man you've given us motivation you know
what you take stuff as entrepreneurs you
know we always need that motivation so
and thank you can be a movie about you
know because I came of the day when
we're making content you to social
whatever we're gonna make mistakes right
we're not it's never going to be perfect
but the point is you learn from it you
get better and I'm sure like you seen
your videos today you're probably like
finding things I want to make this
better next time you know and you make
things even better and your videos are
unbelievable so i don't know if i could
get any better but i know you and you
fall you don't push yourself to elk
after do this to dismiss so that also
take us to and tell us tickets to a time
maybe tickets to what what would you say
is one of the most epic social moments
um 50 cent shared the video of his
tomorrow all put together and that's a
good story because we spent you know my
work so my eye before
time researcher and his job is to find
the videos and take the best chunks and
he spent like eight hours just some 50
cent trying to find clips and I looked
at it and and I wasn't happy with it you
know it's like this is not it's good but
it's not like I didn't feel it enough
and sometimes the people just they don't
have enough good points but I felt 50
cent like you can have something and so
then I then spent more hours finding
them myself too late in the night to
find that the final clips that we would
send and that's what made it into the
final version and I was unhappy with it
and and I don't know 50 cent and I you
know I didn't know how or if it would
ever get to him I didn't know that this
would all play out but he somehow got it
he shared it on his Twitter on his
facebook on his website and that video
blew up ah ok but like would he have
done it if we didn't put in the extra
work to make it really really solid I
don't know maybe maybe not but I also at
the same time expect the entrepreneur
profiling to see it and be proud of it
right it's not like Oh 50 Cent's all
this while is amazing like yeah this is
a really good video this is some
life-changing stuff so like that's a
goal going in is that you know any we
want the person to see it and be proud
of it and be like that was a really good
quality video so that's a tent always
going in yeah because as those people on
there in the celebrity life they have
people talking on bottom on the gossip
you're always kind of stuff you know
wiki says going broke and all this stuff
and here's a great video the guys built
the unbelievable business and what
you're able to do with those videos
showcase I can say to entrepreneurs what
makes this person take what makes this
successful right what what and none of
them was the same but you can see some
are you know they got some of the
similar consists of things that you know
happen and so but it's really cool i'm
sure if they're probably the majority of
the people that are you know pushing out
the videos you think the majority of the
people are seeing or their public
relations people are seeing them um i
don't know i don't know how long he gets
back to them a number of people have
written to us to say thank you for
future me so i have shared it and I
expect more like I
is as the channel gets more successful
as we get better at picking and making
the videos I only expect more people to
to see it and want to share it and be
proud of it and that's like I expect
that to happen we're designing it with
that intent it's going to happen if I
got those videos are unbelievable like I
said I that's why stuck when I literally
met Evan was browsing some more about
the videos and then boom that Nvidia
that the other ten rules video comes up
and then I just start fall in love with
the other one I was like what is it AZ
have to say oh if you see I just started
seeing entrepreneurs and I wanted to get
to know and I never got a chance to know
it's so hard on me too because there's
so many videos and you can spend hours
and hours and hours of your time wasting
time with all this I'll be real we only
have so much time of the day we can't go
back into the future so with your videos
it's awesome because you're able to
really cops fear that whole moat with
them and it'd be like 10 15 20 minutes
not like three hours a day you know
because like i said i found that i'm
watching warm-up videos and watching
yours he says the same things you say
just repeatedly over and over again
throughout hours of video I mean I still
feel watching cuz I like more but the
blood for entrepreneurs out there join
my manage channel because you'll get an
education and business but also people
you love you know people you love and
then who is wanting to get to know
outside of baby visits entertainment
athletes and stuff like that so that's
awesome maybe I'll one day a suggestion
if you can a man Jerry Jones I don't
know if we did one or not I need to
switch the channel Jerry Jones the owner
Dallas Cowboys out how long he's on our
list he's on our list we haven't done it
yet we haven't done it but he's on our
linear 15 man so we got to give him
going baby so that works instantly mine
said oh my god Evan Carmichael with some
beaver lows telling my man tells if
today a perfect world who live anywhere
where would it be I love Toronto man i
decide i love in the shots to the
hometown Toronto this is this offers the
basketball grapplers a sports I'm a
baseball fan wow we got the Blue Jays
here we had a good shot last year yes
what happens this year yeah Laurent God
was a great
please Donald they can we go yeah yeah
for sure of course man the local my
hometown out here I'm nice yeah we don't
have many guys in the in the major
league baseball but he's at the Blue
Jays and he's awesome he's a great
hitter yeah MVP yeah I mean Toronto's a
great place it's a great place to visit
a great place to live I've traveled
around to lots of different cities but
but really enjoy calling Toronto my home
although I love asking that because a
lot of times people say they're up there
at where their dream of living in it
just needs a shout out to where you're
at you don't then the fun part of it for
you i know you're traveling all over
speaking and getting out for to the
travel but it's nice to have that
hometown and be there where you love you
know Jenna favorite type of food out in
Toronto favorite kind of food in Toronto
yeah I don't know man ah do we have some
you know I like Tim Hortons coffee
where's my Tim Hortons yeah there you go
you can shut up cool good morning let's
get you fired up there you go so do you
chop can you also tell us what is one of
your next big dreams I'm it's
interesting because I don't have huge
dreams when I see when I have something
in my mind I just start working on it
you know it sounds like I wish I didn't
hear anything today it's like I'm going
like you know I wanted to build a house
and then I found the plot of land i
started building a house I don't have
like an odd years i'm going to do this
we just I just do it I start doing it um
so in that context you know my bigger
goal is to help a billion entrepreneurs
you want to do big projects to help
entrepreneurs right now my two main
focuses are the YouTube channel adding
the content and you see the hustle there
and the other side is the book so I'm
writing the book with penguin Random
House that comes out december six or 7th
Wow Oh both about the book process like
what do you what your goal the book I
think you can't say everything but what
what's the mold of it ah the topic of
the book I haven't revealed yet but I
mean a lot of the topics that we talk
about it similar to things that are
other channel um again like I want I
only want to do things that can have a
big impact so
with a huge publisher there's a lot of
effort that's going to go behind it I
wanted to reach millions of people
that's if it's not if you can't have
that impact I don't want to do it or in
December my man I will be supporting
with my whole team giving you a shout
outs love reading the book I could tell
you right now I'm a huge fan anyone that
thinks that they know it all they need
to be slapped in the face a little bit
because we all have something to learn
from each other right i mean it's like
the littlest things that's why i love
the show is to today I'm learning Evans
passion but also i'm building a
friendship with my man I've never got to
know you besides through your videos but
I can see in you a passionate I love
this just do it i would say it might
speak when i talk people just do you
just like nike just to you because sofa
so many of us gets caught up in oh I got
to get things done and like you said the
five-year plan it's like oh wait that's
tomorrow and start working right like
big things figured out nothing's going
to be perfect but we're gonna if you get
things done in life you're gonna be a
winner at whatever you do I can promise
you that you're gonna win some races you
might not want them all but you will win
and that's what I love about what you're
doing it specifically what you're
putting out there for entrepreneurs to
it's like that don't be afraid right
don't be afraid because it has to be
perfect it's like everything can be
revised edited for you know an iteration
there's over that version 2 there's all
sorts of things you can do but we're
never going to be perfect if you sit
back and are waiting on the sidelines
yeah even if you let me obviously you
love the top 10 series looking at that
that's gone through some changes from
the first videos to where we are now how
I presented the format at the point
there's a lot of it that's changes
scheduling I so like I'll bump it up get
some feedback and then and then make it
better yeah I love that bad so thank you
for sharing that because I think that's
one of the biggest secrets of
entrepreneurs to is willing to just keep
mark working right he wanted to just
feel like you said whatever I dream up I
don't have an X big dreams I'm doing it
right now can you tell us and tell me
how do you typically like to start your
day I think I'm morning routine is
really important I feel like a lot of
people get all excited because they got
inspired by something and then and then
well okay maybe if you
listen to this show hey I'm getting real
drive this job Jonna know right really
baby let's go and it's like three
o'clock on a Tuesday afternoon and then
you know I'm fired up for the rest of
the day and then I wake up Wednesday
morning as poof it's gone right and so I
think it's important to design an
environment that supports you to build
something great every day with intention
that's part of the top 10 series in the
ants presso series learning from these
famous entrepreneurs I want to start my
day with that so that I have steve jobs
in my head and Warren Buffett in my head
and Walt Disney my head pushing me to
want to do more and not happen but by
accident that sometime in the afternoon
I happened to read a book and that
inspires me or something rightly with
intention design and environment
designer morning routine that supports
you to do something great and most
people have a morning routine that's
that's just by accident you're just
reacting to the world you're getting up
according to somebody else's schedule
I'm getting up because I have this
meeting with somebody else to go meet
them not I'm doing this for me to be
great I'm doing this to build something
amazing so what what has to happen in
your schedule to help you build
something amazing every day so sure so
true and tuba Divas get caught up of
emails and all that kind of stuff
fighting the fires instead of thinking
of our own intentions and purpose that's
what I love you say having that morning
attention you can go with what you want
you know get hit the day going here you
give us and tell us what is some of the
best advice you ever see the best advice
I ever got was from my parents love
taught me to believe in myself that's
where this comes from they always told
me that I was at my mom's last name is
cuz truly they taught me that I was a
cost really Carmichael and I could do
anything and that made me believe in
myself and it's not like business advice
like how to raise capital or how to make
a sales call or you know any of those
things but the the foundation for me is
is belief in having self-confidence and
feeling like I can accomplish whatever I
set my mind to shape to IM and i brought
that into the
this I've got a lot of business advice
not from my parents because they're not
entrepreneurs they don't understand that
world much but they set me up for life
they set me up to be a successful human
being in whatever I wanted to go and
accomplish ah from a very early age and
so I try to encourage that in my son too
and also through like the channel is all
about believe I want people to watch in
a lot of cases you know my videos are
the only thing that is inspiring people
to do something great like they don't
have any belief in themselves or in
their life and in their environment and
the videos that we create help even a
little bit in a little way help them
have a little bit more confidence and
that's a huge responsibility and also a
huge honor which is why I keep doing it
it's going to keep on going to those are
you I've already joined I think where I
kind of addicted to your videos to be
honestly I look for when i'm looking at
my subscriptions if I news video if I'm
like which ones they was going to have
up and if they catch my interest i'm
right there watching it you know so i
love i love your passion because what it
takes is to never give up and just
believe in yourself like you say but
also know that the world is full of
abundance there's Mark Zuckerberg out
there that's giving away 99% of his
money and he made 45 billion dollars
before he was 30 years old there's an
abundance of wealth wellness friendships
you know and just be yourself I always
like to stay be real don't feel I get to
fake it no [ __ ] could be someone else
like you said just be who you are right
just be who you are but have your own
dreams not just silly you have to follow
someone else's dreams like he inspired
by them but not but have your own
Patrick how girls we only have one life
right we only got one shot at this life
and if you're not yourself you're going
to be a regret if you said I'm gonna be
a being which is this you're not you're
not regretful of anything because you
are literally right behind you believe
you're living it you're living it every
day and I'm sure it's only going to get
bigger and bolder and better and
everything you know it's great with that
but you already built something that
you've got to be so proud of me so shout
out to my van Emmon for you keep me
inspired every day as an auction or
entrepreneur to who we take you to the
hot seat my man where you can share some
last-minute phenomenal resources and a
couple more real clock answers let's do
it not tonight for dinner if you
meet anyone in the world and have dinner
with them who to be um AP Giannini oh
wow who is that tell me about I've my
muffler founder of Bank of America oh my
favorite entrepreneur of all time he
obviously passed away um but he he was
the belief banker you may think banker
banker zone entrepreneur bakers you know
they're not really friendly they're
entrepreneurs but he was a guy who you
know when San Francisco blew up with
from the from the fire there's a huge
fire with this bang and everybody was
closed and people needed access to their
money everything was closed he's hit up
two barrels and put a plank of wood
across it and started loaning money to
people based on a handshake and a look
in their eye uh and he believed in
helping you know he was at one of the
first guys to lend money to immigrants
into new people coming into the country
where banks only lent money to safe you
know big business he bet on a young
entrepreneur named Walt Disney when
nobody would give that guy a chance was
he wanted to make cartoons into full
length movies are you crazy and so like
he was the entrepreneurs banker and he
really believed in the little guy so wow
what a cool story see what I'm have to
look I've actually a bank of america
investor so i shouldn't be doing this
kind of stuff I guess it's uh but I
appreciate it you know there's so much
to learn out there like I always say you
know don't feel bad if you don't know
everything and I'm just all you do is
take notes and if you got a top ten
rules I'm gonna watch this one if you
got one up so I've watch this one and so
give him a shout out again it was AP
Giannini at that yeah that's it that's
it I mean even bank of america does a
terrible job of telling his story a lot
of people there wouldn't even know who
he was i have no idea i'm a little an
investor in bank of america you know I'm
private investor but still I mean it's
you should you should feel that
connection like you said we all know all
this we all know with the dogs you know
it's a little unschooled now but you
know people to kind of tend to know the
founders uh envio that's a good point
that you know they really should maybe
think about that being that today in
days today's day and age story telling
them everything tell another story
everything that's why people buy into
you
that's why people are for your channel
you're walking totem of story of their
life in 10 or 15 minutes but it really
hits you because it's not just BS it's
like hip impactful point after a packer
point after a packer party like boom
boom and you get up and die wow that was
awesome that was like literally my
feeling my first video with you so shout
out to my man if he did suggest any
favorite internet tool or after you like
using on database is going to be
internet tool or app um interesting I'm
in the Fitbit right now I'm are I'm via
a mission I'm in that challenge right
now I hit fifty thousand steps yesterday
oh good job Evan what am I get now 35 so
I still got it I still got something to
go um do instead the standing office and
kind of moving around at the same time
yeah I've had a sending us for six or
seven years um but the Fitbit is
relatively new like maybe past eight
months fan attack man I wouldn't say my
man you look pretty buff over there are
you looking good well the getting good
there you go oh cool fifty thousand
steps that's a good accomplishment shout
out to Fitbit to for making such a cool
tool to kind of keep us all accountable
1 i'm gonna be it's gonna be amazing to
see what they come up with from the
future i heard that our own you know a
lot of our Diagnostics of our health and
stuff like that will come from tools
like Fitbit counting are you know blood
pressure and sort of things that we
normally go to the doctor for will the
views you know using tools like 15 so
shout to them we're creating such a pool
easy to use product right yeah i had to
pick a business one I can't go with
Evernote okay yeah all new stuff and
keeping everything in one place and also
you know we manage a lot of the YouTube
channel to Evernote why do I have open
both full-time I'm a full-time editor I
have a part-time editor and a full-time
researcher who all share the same
folders and we can update it and so it's
just super helpful to keep notes between
each other to everyone you gotta know on
the same page so shadows ever know yeah
it's a great tool great tool on all
platforms uh also the detail
what can you suggest as we book a book
to our listeners do you think look
inspire them the book that I'm reading
right now is onward by Howard Schultz
onward okay I've heard about that one ah
pretty cool book I'm really digging it
its founder of starbucks right and it's
about the turnaround of when he left and
then he came back uh so yeah I'm taking
a lot of notes I'm a fan on earth onward
and I would you do physically read the
books or audio books how do you typical
add to go about that I read the book as
a way to wind down just before so we're
in bed uh well my friend I have no
electronics in the room so like falling
iPad everything is just outside the door
let's say that over the way that's
awesome and then nice judging by the way
yeah and so then we just we just have
you know some candles a little light and
we each read whatever ring too so she's
reading something i'm reading non-word
and died a chapter to whatever then
crush her yeah that's cool man that's
cool I like that I like that not having
the devices you know an hour to before
bed time getting that little sore so
caught up you got phones I've has tech
think that all this stuff in it's like
that quiet time right it was still human
beings and need some quiet time it's
like meditation along if you want to
call it to read a book and get some
insight and then hey it put you to sleep
you have a good drink you know and then
so look at our screen and show it up the
news feed okay you know it gives the
eyes are bring to that's what they say a
lot of doctors i thought i've talked to
they say a lot of I did you can happen
from social media and things like that
because we're just staring at the screen
right up tell us also get a couple of
selections for you is there a skill in
the future that you want to master this
is another one of those things bro you
know like if I want to master something
I'll just dive in and start learning it
real answer Todd cuando or like you know
so salsa was one that I wanted to learn
and I learned it right I walk into a
class now I go to school I
Wow I learn it um I don't really have
here's I wish I could do this right like
just go do it yeah uh uh I love that
passion that you have there for that
because it's so true it's like stop the
BS get up off your couch like Gary
Vaynerchuk says you have five pins to
12am at night every single night or
sitting around doing something feeling
around off business hours all your
dreams can happen right there I like
everything can happen right there but
you also have to not be afraid like my
Matt Evans says he's just he's a taco so
any skill he has he's like all right
chronic boom salsa boom you know and I
love that because you can't be afraid
and you're living proof that this can
happen on a huge scale I mean way bigger
than your dreams called and you have one
of the biggest influences on YouTube but
I think you're one of the best content
creators out there for a business
channel anyone that wants to get inside
on entrepreneurship business if there
are subscribed to your channel they
better go do that right now I thought to
say because I've learned a lot my man
and I've been in the business for a
while but still like I said you can't be
afraid to learn something every day and
you're doing amazing thing for us and
you're not asking us for anything so I'm
just a hey enjoyed so I appreciated that
I appreciated that my dude can you give
our listeners will last real talk
thought and then also how can our
listeners gonna hold it what do you want
man what's the real talk fun anything
you want hi anything i won yeah anything
you want yeah um you know I think to sum
everything up the most important thing
to look at is is again back to
environment look at what your morning
routine is look at what your habits are
look at your physical environment like
you know there's a reason why I have the
statue of Guan Yu here is the reason why
this you know my logo on the wall is the
reason why I'm wearing this shirt is a
reason for that and you want to create
an environment with intent because you
can force yourself and will yourself to
do something for only so long where you
always end up falling back to whatever
is expected of you in the environment
that you have and most people don't
create that on purpose they just happen
to live there and so you're the result
of your parents expectations and your
friends expectations and your city's
expectations and to break free you need
to create an environment for greatness
um I had just a couple of thoughts on
the extending the learning thing won't
think about like why I don't want to
learn something or don't have a like in
five years I want to learn this skill
yeah you just know enjoyed it yeah and
and it's important one because i often
it's not as hard as you think it's gonna
be right so is like on five years i'm
going to learn french trying to learn
snowboarding and you build it up as this
big thing that you can't start right now
because you see there's this huge block
to get over but once you start into it
you realize it's actually not that bad
and why did you wait so long to try it
right like I kick yourself for waiting
so long I should have done that five
years ago the other thing is you may not
like it either like you build this thing
up that in five years i'm going to learn
spanish and then you start like you know
i don't like spanish it's like you waste
all this time on irrelevant stuff we're
just try it see if you like it when I
wanted to learn snowboarding you know I
went so bird with my wife she taught me
one year on New Year's Eve new year's
day we went New Year's snowboarding
named and I did I'd never said word in
my life and I sucked and I fell on my
ass and boom it was terrible and I
wanted to get better and so I went that
the next season because the season was
over the next season I went I got a
snowboard I went every day slow morning
is this a hit small hill next to my
office and I went every day I would push
meetings I would start every day
snowboarding and I got better and in
that one season I got better than her
and and our friends ah and then and then
the passion fate is like yeah okay I'm
good enough now like I can still bar
with them that's it I don't need to get
better but it's not like in 10 years I
want to be a good snowboarder I just
found the way to do it was interesting
it was exciting when you are when you
are drawn to something with your passion
just start don't wait till next year
then wait till tomorrow you have an idea
do something right now I'm totally agree
i would say your dreams can happen with
one hour a week it doesn't take a lot
like you said you have to practice
though if you even just practice one
hour a week playing the guitar learning
spanish going snowboarding in 52 weeks
you're going to be a lot better like you
took the extreme amount that's i love
that even better
extreme if you're all about it you know
but some of them say like they know the
excuse me it's like you have one hour
you got one hour in a whole week and if
you practice like you always mention
it's like if you take those both little
baby steps you can get anything one and
everything everything we save I believe
it's so true and believe in yourself is
so true because if you want it you take
the action and you get and serves no
there's no doubt about the world will
give it to you the universe has your
best intentions but you have to be that
person that pushed yourself to do it you
no one else is going to pick you up off
the sea life Oh chocolates go do this
hey Travers go interview heaven today oh
hey China is gonna start to be Roadshow
no they're not and they don't care and
they don't want to but I do and that way
we have the show just like you have your
sins hugely successful show because no
one told you to do it it's something you
wanted to do but you haven't stopped
either and that's why it's going to be
since the momentum factor you have all
this content now everybody with you you
push out now it's a lot more because you
can be linked back to all the other past
one I can subscribe now and watch all
other content right and that's the
biggest part of it Plus to be honest
with you I love watching the concert on
man so keep it up I appreciate you being
on the show today can you Rochelle
listeners at holiday house best you'd
like to have them get ahold of you I'm
you know since your frame of the youtube
channel then just go to youtube with
type and Evan Carmichael and you'll
finally your fireman easy got about five
hundred thousand videos are there how
many goodies you have on your channel by
the way right now ah just over 3,000 Wow
we'll keep it up a man i want to thank
you so much for being on the B rochelle
and thank you for so much for introduce
me to your audience as well and i hope
to have you back on the show is
somewhere here december so so we can
talk about the book you can give our
listeners and some more insights it's a
feedback about well you know your but
i'm really excited about that I
appreciate it man thanks for having me
all right oh thank you yes you saw all
right hey we want to take a few
questions sure um okay just kidding
nightcore saying what is the worst thing
you had to sacrifice in order to become
sick
and was it worth it I mean honestly the
worst thing you're always going to have
to success you know sacrifice and
business to be successful is going to be
sometimes your friendships I mean
sometimes you're just not going to have
the time to go span golfing with your
buddies if you have friendships out
there as you're growing your business to
be real with you you know there's going
to be friendships that you're gonna have
to say okay I can spend time with you
but it's gonna have to be on the weekend
there's certain things like that just
changed as obviously life changes but I
found that as growing my business that
was one of the areas that I always want
to be friends with everybody and keep
the relationship though it's not you
just can't you just got to say hey be
real yourself hey if I want to be a
success I got to do me most importantly
and some of those friendships are going
to have to be you know not who I can go
to spend so much time playing video
games on the couch and things like that
when you're in the college days you know
because that's just part of life right
would you agree Evan I'm trying to think
what the biggest you know I don't spend
a lot of time on the negative stuff yeah
I don't know I try not to either
actually but i would say i just always
expect to be brought up that was what
came to me first when I was because I
feel sometimes like you I'm you know you
get you at home and I need a seat I see
these people's posts on Facebook and
things like that and I feel connected to
them but you just wish you could go have
an extra time to spend time with them at
lunch and things like that you just
don't get the chance to do if you build
a successful business for yourself and
you have your magic tiara stuff like
you're doing you're just going to have
to the most important priority is once
you get done in the day first and then
if you have time in the day getting a
lunch or something like that that's
great but if you don't get your goal
done first nothing else matters I think
that's my opinion I think for me it's uh
it's time away it's opportunity cost
like I'm conscious about losing time I
hate losing time yeah whether it's time
away from my family or time away from
doing something important I don't see it
as a negative though I use it as a way
to fuel me so as an example I went to
Madrid last week and I was helping I was
keynote in this speech to librarians how
librarians can be relevant in today's
generation oh nice and I was there for
almost a week from sunday to thursday i
was there and the only had me doing two
things
one keynote speech and then one question
and answer session and I was pissed
because I'm sitting walking around the
streets of Madrid and it's all I like
beautiful city of love Madrid but like I
don't want to be on vacation guys I
don't I want to inspire people and have
make a change in librarians and one of
these librarians doesn't go off and
build the next Great Library of
Alexandria I'm gonna be pissed that I
wasted my time yes they like they paid
me to be there and great but it's much
more about the time that I spend has to
be impactful that's in line with my goal
of helping a billion entrepreneurs and
so I use that and I use that like pissed
off mindset to make me deliver awesome
when I got on stage because I'm there
for two things for like an hour and a
half and i gotta bring it or this whole
thing was a waste of time so i use that
as pressure on myself um so I've
sacrificed I guess other things like
I've spent my time on something that
means I can't spend my time somewhere
else but I use that recognition to then
fuel the raising the stakes making this
more important to me so that I turn up
and I'm my best so true I love that to
use as motivation and say hey I got to
give my best these people are never
going to see me again and if I spent all
this time like you said to not deliver
and not take someone's life you know
it's kind of we've all been in those
four more important presentations right
so I love like your energy I can just
imagine you're turning up baby yeah yeah
turn up the dial I love it that's
awesome cool well Travis thank you for
spending the time thank you guys for
watching you can check out the beer ale
podcast I linked it up in the
description and I appreciate them and
when is this episode going live we will
go live probably in about two weeks
he'll be going live on the audio at
about two weeks and thank you guys so
much so much Evan my man thank you for
being who you are my man you may be
believed I promise you i watch your
videos I subscribe I absolutely love
what you're doing for entrepreneurs it
anything I can do to help you get to
your 1 billion entrepreneurs got me I'm
on github I'm
you're back I'm ready to walk with you
my man so keep it up in you feeling the
love man feeling the love I'll talk to
you soon everybody thank you